so one is win-win
so one key thing about this uh
selfishness and the idea of objectivism
is the philosophy of love
is that you don't want parasitism
so that goes that is unethical so you
actually
it's first of all you say win win a lot
and i i just like that terminology
because
it's a good way to see life it's try to
maximize
the number of win-win interactions
absolutely that's a good way to see
business
actually well life generally i think
every aspect of life
you want to have a win-win relationship
with your wife imagine if it was
wouldn't lose
either way if you win and she loses how
long is that going to
sustain so win lose relationships are
not
in equilibrium what they turn into is
lose lose
like win lose turns into lose lose and
the so the alternative the only
alternative to lose loses win win
and you win and the person you love wins
what's better than that
right that's the way to maximize so like
the
selfishness is you're trying to maximize
the win but the way to maximize the win
is to to maximize the win win yes and it
turns out
and adam smith understood this a long
time ago that if you focus on your own
winning
while respecting other people as human
beings then everybody wins and the
beauty of capitalism if we go back to
capitalism for a second
the beauty of capitalism is you cannot
be successful in capitalism
without producing values that other
people appreciate and therefore willing
to buy from you
and they buy them and this goes back to
that question about the engineer and
steve jobs
why is the engineer working there
because he's getting paid more than his
time is worth to him
i know people don't like to think in
those terms but that's the reality
if his time is worth more to him than
what he's getting paid he would leave
so he's winning and is apple winning yes
because they're getting more
productivity from him they're getting
more from him
than what he's actually producing
you